President Trump says he's ready for
another government shutdown tomorrow if
he doesn't get the immigration reforms
he wants the president said quote I'd
love to see a shutdown
he spoke while top Republicans and
Democrats on Capitol Hill praised the
recent progress they've made in their
budget negotiations the president held a
discussion of gang violence yesterday at
the White House he wants Congress to
approve 25 billion dollars for a wall
along the border with Mexico plus new
limits on legal immigration
congressional leaders want to settle the
budget issue before they get to
immigration and border security Margit
Brennan is at the White House with the
story market good morning good morning
while congressional negotiators appear
to be closing in on a deal to boost
military spending and set funding levels
for two years but if this agreement
falls through there's no clear plan on
how to keep the government open past
midnight tomorrow I'd love to see a
shutdown president Trump threatened
another government shutdown if his
border security demands are not met if
we don't change it let's have a shutdown
will do a shutdown and it's worth it for
our country but even fellow Republicans
at the table oppose a shutdown virginia
congresswoman barbara Comstock we don't
need a government shutdown on this we
really do I think both sides have
learned that a government shutdown was
bad and you can say what you want we're
not getting support from the Democrats
the president shutdown threat came as
both parties on Capitol Hill were
actually close to a deal to avert one I
think we're on the way to getting an
agreement but the proposed two-year
spending bill would not include any
immigration changes last month's
shutdown ended after Democrats were
promised a vote by Republicans on
protections for dreamers the
undocumented immigrants who came to the
US as children the current protection
expires on March 5th but President Trump
has offered a potential pathway to
citizenship for 1.8 million dreamers in
exchange for 25 billion dollars in
border security White House chief of
staff John Kelly questioned why only six
hundred ninety thousand had previously
signed up for protection some would say
were too afraid to sign up others
say we're too lazy to get off their
asses but they didn't sign up later on
Kelly was asked to explain the remark
some of them just should have probably
gotten off the couch and signed up but
then it doesn't really matter how
because President Trump has given them
the status now if the president was
really adamant he could veto the plan
that both sides are working on if it
doesn't include his request for border
wall funding but yesterday White House
press secretary Sarah Sanders said
despite what the president had earlier
said the White House is not advocating
for a shutdown Nora all right Margaret
thank you